Let's go next to our caller from the three
to three area code.
Who is calling today from three to three.
Hey David, some Chino.
Hey Gina and I just have a concern.
Hey, I just have a concern about the wealth
tax that has been talked about by Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders.
Um, the thing is that I don't think that a
lot of the wealth that I'm doing there's,
have, is liquid enough for, for it to be taxed.
And I've heard a lot of countries have tried
to what tax, but it hasn't worked the way
they want it.
You're actually, you're correct.
I've mentioned this before.
I've mentioned this before and listen, this
is not about let's feel sorry for billionaires
whose wealth is all tied up in stocks and
co corporate ownership.
I'm not saying that it is a practical consideration
that other countries have dealt with that
wealth taxes on people who don't necessarily
have a lot of cash can create situations where
they need to sell stocks in order to be in
compliance with the wealth tax or do other
things.
This is why it feels as though lower hanging
fruit would be taxing capital gains at the
same rate as ordinary income because then
you're taxing the, the gains on the wealth
rather than the, uh, the, the wealth itself,
which may be held in illiquid assets.
Now I, I'm guessing that there are counter
arguments, but you are correctly stating,
Gino, this has been a problem in other countries
and I completely agree with you on that.
Yeah, I don't, I'm sure the think it's, or
I don't feel sorry for billionaires or anything,
it's just that I just, I just want it to be
taxed in an efficient way.
We get to the money we need for the programs
that we need.
Totally.
Yeah.
I mean it sounds like you and I are on the
same page that thank you for the call.
Yeah, it sounds like we're both on the same
page, that we're not against a wealth tax
morally and we're not against what it's trying
to do and we don't, we're not against reducing
inequality, but we have some concerns about
the implementation of such attacks.